σημονις όδηματοσο μεγαλότωντα πο σωστά που καταναλώνων του διτομείς και τίπριακάομ θέλι μια στρότι γίνοτον
το πρ καικαι να γαλούμε και μπαίνούμε στο λάθος τον αστό χεφτων παύοχόν δι ότιναι
είσαι πολίτης κάθεσς πσος σου λένε μάλιστα θορίς τον λογαριασμόν του ρεύματοςβλέπεις τον λοαριασμών των
τροφήμο τω ψημική ψηγίουσου το καλαθιο της οικοκεράς το βλέπεις να υξάνεικαι σου λέει μια
κυβέρνηση θα βάρει ε κατόν ευρώ αύξεσε ολιώρα δεν και ξέρεις ότι άλλος έποιαχύλια υρόξέντε
στρόματα ισοδηματικά πάνω που σε ανα ή το ξέρ και κίνε βρίζεσαι αλλά καιντυρώ ναποια
στα κατό ευρώ και πολλά καλάαμες δταφρειάζεσου το πρόληα όμως ενεληθηκε και η δουλειά μας
δεν είνα κάπνουμε να δίνουμε χάποιο ας πηρίνι στον δημοθαναο στον ετιμοθάνατο η δουλειά μας
εν αλιούμεν το πρόβλημα τ τοιμοθάνα του και να μηντ νδιμιουργούμετού την ανισότετα με στην
κοινωνία να την επιδίνουμε να εμείς ίδη που τες ενέργειας μας άρα πως λιούμενο τα
προλιααολικός χειρειασμό και ολικς σχεασμός και εδοκαι εδώ σε σε σημεία μποράια να συμφωνούμε σε
πολλά σημεία ενέργειών πουργινώνται όπως αρκετά σημία ιστεγαστικής κατεύθυσης που λαμβανειοκρατος αλλά σε άλλά επιμέρους
σημεία μποράδιαφωνούμε ςτο τι γίνεται τι γίνεται όμοσ έχουμε υπάμετους πορος ι οποίο κατευθύνουν τεστημές
αυτό το θεμάτοπρώτο θέμακάποις φορολογικό εκάνετο κάνε ένα φορολογική με τα ρίθμηση με κάνει α
αφότεροό κουρεμαινα μέ έναναψευτός ασμα φορολογικό ισε τους πολίτες οι οποιοι είναιτώς του φορολογικού φορολογιταίουση
τοδηματος εκείνους που πληρώνου φορολογια αλλά ποια ξ τους πολίτες με κάποιον τρόπο πυ εγκάτω
π τοφς